[Music]
you know
[Music]
one of these villagers like us traveling
forwards through time the other one's
going backwards
can you tell which is which
how about now
why does it feel so strange you're not
shooting the bullet
you're catching it whoa i didn't win
back in my cell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
for a diplomat there are people in the
future
who need us
[Music]
you get something i'm not gonna like
time isn't the problem getting out alive
is a problem
[Music]
well i'm going so any tips will be
welcome ain't no timer
what do you think we're saying
the detritus of a coming
[Music]
you want to crash a plane well how big a
plane
that part is a little dramatic
last time it was no tennis pg-13
impossible
a woman leading a man's army
it is my duty to fight for the kingdom
the girl who has come to save the
dynasty
[Applause]
you will die pretending to be something
you are not
yet here i stand
i will bring honor to us all disney's
mulan
rated pg-13 streaming september 4th
exclusively available to disney plus
subscribers with premier access
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
your time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
feel like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well that's my turn
get used to it never been one for rules
the answer is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you
what radar will they will they shoot at
[Applause]
[Music]
us
barbara what did you do you know i'm not
so keen on this one i figure uh
you are but you know what i'm ready to
go i think we can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
[Music]
the romance of the desert
has the power to seduce
[Music]
i ask you
[Music]
have you ever loved so much
[Music]
been so possessed by jealousy
that you might kill them
you had something to hide
the crime is murdered
is one of you i don't feel safe here
i don't feel safe with any of that it's
too late
to change events it's time to face
[Music]
and i will deliver your killer many
great stories
are tragedies
[Music]
from your secret friends
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why's he writing to you if you
are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
you're part of this too
how am i part of it
you'll see
[Music]
fine you're fine you always use a condom
so you're fine
hey dude i've got this thing
if a young woman needs a procedure is
that possible
where's the closest facility there's an
albuquerque in missouri
the law won't let me get one without my
parents knowing
i know we're not close anymore true and
i'm the last person that you want to
help
accurate but i need your help and i
don't have anywhere else to go go
where to get the thing the procedure so
you're hiding this from your man
your best friend hey girl and your jesus
freak parents and you thought
why not ask bailey butler to drive me
hundreds of miles because she probably
doesn't have anything to do anyway
kind of yes bailey bailey come on
i'm just messing with you you're right i
do not have anything going on
i thought you drove a camry
[Music]
oklahoma texas new mexico
will be in albuquerque by tomorrow night
uh-huh no
and we'll be home sunday evening
i'm setting the alarm for 5 a.m
self-care huh i had to post something so
people wouldn't bother me of course
so people wouldn't know you're with me
we both know you wouldn't do the same
for me you made it really hard to be
your friend
i'm sorry that i couldn't be perfect for
you all the time i needed you to be
perfect
i appreciate everything you've done for
me
why are they looking at the car i see my
mom's boyfriend's car we're driving a
stolen
car if you don't help us out we're gonna
be in so much trouble
i don't think that this is what you
really want it's my life it's my choice
[Music]
the lord but you don't really
care for music do you
it goes like this the fourth
the fifth the minor fall the major lift
the baffled king composing
[Music]
[Applause]
hallelujah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i did my best it wasn't much
i couldn't feel so i tried to touch
i've told the truth that didn't come
before the lord
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
this guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won
i don't care how many demons he's fought
and how many hells
he's never fought us not us united
there she is guess what
daddy is going to get you dressed for
school today
we are descendants of the gods
this land was always ours but we must
never relent
we're nowhere and everywhere
you're from virginia right i can tell
you're special we are the future
you you're not like the others
[Music]
whoever you were before
that's over
[Music]
what are we doing what is
the plan
[Applause]
wrinkle tonight
9-1-1 what is your emergency
you mind if i join you guys tess don't
look now but there's a boy staring at us
i think he's staring at you oh right you
are and keep me down
tell me something just for me first time
i saw you was right after spiros
introduced me in front of the class
it was a good first impression
[Music]
caitlyn was cute airy hardly a reason to
pop like a zit
what happened caitlyn exploded what like
a bomb no like a
balloon what
will i get these back do you want these
back
in the hell are they gonna let us out of
here when they know it's not gonna
happen again then what's gonna happen
again
it happened again a lot you know you
can't keep
it good listen everyone's scared duh
duh kids are literally blowing up
[Music]
i think they're doing tests on us what's
your name for the record please
you can ask my lawyer i have a moment
for you where i knew i liked you
you liked me i just bought it today
why i was saving up for a college car
but then i thought
i might die tomorrow that should be our
school slogan
what's gonna happen to us
at least now you can't say things are so
much harder back in my day
you're right you have a way worse
can i help you sir you can help me find
maria all maria's gone we're completely
self-checkout now
please scan your item please scan your
item i just did please scan your item
yeah right
sir this can't keep happening
[Music]
you're not putting me in a hall what if
it were our home
grandpa hi grandpa hello sweetheart
how's your daughter's place that she
gave me my grandson's room he's not too
happy about it how do you like your room
okay look i didn't want it to be this
way either
i just want my room back get away from
me
ah come on i want to put up with this
piece
i demand my room back or else it's more
declaration of war
give me back what is mine let's face the
consequences
okay okay you got your wish
what the fast drying foam ceiling i'm
gonna get this too
so let me get this straight you want me
to help you and your buddies help beat
up your grandson and his buddies because
the two of you can't figure out some way
to live in the same
house well when you put it like that i'm
in this kind of aggression
i didn't know you were a marine it
wasn't
just saying let's do this
do you guys even remember how to play
dodgeball so you don't need your diaper
changed
sure you don't
why are we doing it this way when you
have peace talks you need someone
neutral to mediate
me it is true a cookie was given
i think your grandpa might be a ninja we
gotta end this somehow
[Music]
did you see that
[Music]
[Music]
sir we've landed are we still in all go
we are go
we're dropping a secret team of robots
into a country that we're not supposed
to be in it got serious the moment was
thought up
hey stand up you're all gone well i'll
kill you
do it
[Music]
these people have seen everything take
them all down no witnesses
do you have an id on them yet sending
you a packet special forces huh
this guy is a deserter it could be the
ultimate field test yeah i was thinking
the same thing
she's a doctor they're all doctors
they're here in a good cause
come on man okay you're scaring her
you're scaring me i'm scared
me like a man come on
you were made by humans to affect them
we're different i'm a man i have life
you're a machine candace every day you
call and tell me phineas and ferb have
built some big
unbelievable things and every day i come
home to find
nothing there doesn't it exhaust you
exhaust me
oh look there's nothing here
okay guys i give up what does this one
do
uh candace
where are you going where is she going
candace got abducted by aliens and taken
to another planet
when we step through this portal we're
gonna be on an alien planet
hello and welcome aliens
he's usually harmless if we're going to
rescue kids we need to build a spaceship
like galactic travelinator
you mean like a spaceship but it's an
inethor there's a difference
it's branding leave me alone verb i know
we're gonna do today
we have to pass through an eye on period
yeah so it could fly all of the
electronics on the ship stopping us
in space okay that was something i did
not know
we need to find where they're keeping
candice
[Music]
i know what we're gonna do today it's
me against the universe
what up kids it's cole this is erl
i've traveled all over the world looking
for the wildest experiences to entertain
you guys
you watched commented and told me what
to do next i challenge
all of you to find something that scares
me i dare you come on
we are taking you to an escape room
experience in moscow
i have a buddy named alexi he wants to
take us everywhere
i'm talking the best clubs the best
restaurants this guy's so rich that
everything he does
is the best i've been to escape rooms
man but not one like this because they
make it just for you you have to be
invited
look i get that there are two sides of
you there's this public hole
and there's this private cold i just
don't really know the real you
remember as real as everything might
seem
you're safe sketchy at all
it will begin streaming it directly into
your device from the cameras
let's do it this is crazy
hello
[Music]
what happened here what the hell is this
this is your guy you was just talking
i don't know him all that well what we
were in russia with some guy that you
barely know
are you crazy we don't have our phones
our wallet passports anything we need to
leave now
they change it every single time it's
intense but it's a game
i couldn't say nothing earlier because
he is always watching
hello cole how do you know my name
is
what if this is still part of it no we
lost look at the timer
please let her go mine is just
a little more selective than yours
[Music]
oh yo delete that last part no dude this
is live
[Music]
go tell every village at the foot of
these mountains
the mongols are coming
these are our people
we're all separate but we're all
connected to the one hand
as one family these mongols
[Music]
against the mongols
there's a privilege to die honorably
if we ought to die today i would gladly
die for you
deputy chairman fred hampton of the
illinois black panther party
repeat after me
[Applause]
you're looking at 18 months
for the stolen car five years for
impersonating a federal officer
or you can go home
the black panthers are forming a rainbow
coalition
of oppressed brothers and sisters of
every color their aim
is to show hatred and inspire terror
[Applause]
these ain't no terrorists you can mother
liberate if you can't murder liberation
you're the murder revolutionary but you
can't murder revolution
and you can murder a freedom fighter but
you can't learn
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
i always told you that my family wasn't
in the war
it's not true what are you talking about
we were sleeping when some german
soldiers found us
they did horrible things to the women
worse than you can imagine
what's the likelihood that a guy that
attacked you halfway around the world
15 years ago he ends up two blocks away
louise he's in the trunk
of our car
why are you doing this you don't
remember me your name is carl
i don't know who you're confusing me
with but i'm not in i remember your
whistle you woke us up you hit me
i was never in the war he even looked
the same to you
yes his eyes i will never forget those
eyes i'm not german
i have documents to prove it we need to
be certain
i am certain i need to be certain too
victims of trauma sometimes remember the
smallest details perfect
other times they become confused
we have to release it you don't believe
me
what do you want
i want him to confess
we're gonna get caught why are you
taking care of him
he's right you must know something
i can't even remember how we got back to
the room last night
i wasn't taking some photos there's a
video two and a half hours long
see if we can figure out what happened
[Music]
what are you doing
[Music]
what's on this video is impossible we
watched you snap my neck
we were dosed with something even a
strange drink
special gift for celebrated guests
i was dead how am i standing here
jew haru's
you were nation meant to see what
happened
mommy she knows
[Music]
new
[Music]
[Music]
you